so you talked about earlier just being
busy and getting out there and it leads
to other stuff and it sounds like for
you spare change has also led to
something that's coming up I don't know
if you could talk about it yeah yeah
some how relaxed I am with my handbag on
this chair you know just oh this guy and
a cup of brandy yeah it's a lot of stuff
is snow balled into the way of thinking
after doing spray changes like if you
have an idea write it down or if you do
want to do something just write as much
is it much of it as you can because
there might be someone that wants to
partner with you to make it so always
had this idea for these like horror
shorts and taking kind of the business
model that I learned from the
independent film world and talking to
distributors and kind of coming up with
my own business plan for a couple short
films and how to start there and then
grow that brand a little bit bigger I
got to actually as of last week I
recently signed a deal memo with TV
which is Eli Roth's new digital media
platform and I'm a huge fan of
everything he's done so it's really
really awesome to bring kind of what
myself miss Calvin main who was a camera
assistant on spare change but he's also
a DP cinematographer he does everything
and he and I have always stayed in touch
since we shot and we were like we got to
do a project together so I wanted to see
if he wanted to come on board with this
and he was over the moon about it so he
and I put together our pitch pack at our
business plan and you know kind of made
the right connections and got in on the
phone with whoever we needed to there
and luckily they didn't hate us enough
to throw us out and here we are so we
are in pre-production on those which
worst case scenario they live online and
people can watch them and like them with
this great platform and have the backing
of TV behind us or in best-case
scenario something down the road
develops from a character or a story
from what we're putting together into
something bigger it's really interesting
it's really fun how many webisodes have
you done previously that have led up to
this point where you feel like oh my god
I've I have a web series called the next
steps we have 22 episodes with that
each episodes anywhere from four to five
minutes and something some of the guys
that I've worked with on a lot of
projects helps out behind the scenes
with that and we've gotten featured with
Funny or Die hello giggles website as
well which is awesome because those are
two very different brands and to be able
to appeal to both of them is really cool
in my own perspective and my own view so
the 22 of those I've also done probably
10 to 15 just random one-off short
sketches I did a couple last year called
about around the holidays because those
always seemed to hit and I do comedy
with a group called TMI live and they're
always making new contents we do a show
every Sunday night that streams live on
the stream TV which is really really
exciting it's a brand new sketch show
every week so we've done a lot of videos
and Jack I don't know maybe 35 40 short
form videos that I've either just been
in or have done everything from pre to
post and these new ones for Crypt TV how
long will each segment they'll be short
they're you know somewhere in the two to
five minute range I'll try to tell a
story that makes someone either say oh
that was cool or make someone say oh I'd
like to see more of that you know either
one of those endings we're good with
just you know we don't want people to be
like that was stupid that's our goal for
no one to say that was stupid I'm
setting the bar low
you